welcome back everyone I want you to take
a look at your screen right now
this is sunrise over Gaza City just two
and a half hours from now the official
ceasefire that's been agreed to by
Israel and Hamas will begin but at the
moment there it looks tranquil and
peaceful and we will see if that can
continue for the next two and a half
hours and beyond we will keep you posted
as to what's happening on the ground but
after 27 days of defending itself has
Israel somehow lost more in the eyes of
the world than Hamas has here to debate
that is Ben Shapiro he's the editor in
chief of truth revolt org and Rula
gibreel a foreign policy analyst and
author of the novel morale thanks to
both of you for being here Ben I want to
start with you is it your impression
that in the court of public opinion that
Israel has somehow taken more of a hit
during these 27 days than Hamas has
there's no question I mean Hamas is a
terrorist group in people going in
understood from us to be a terrorist
group Israel thanks hey looks like cNN
has been turned into the villain in this
particular scenario and a moral
equivalency has been drawn between the
two groups if Hamas could have come up
with any sort of outlet that could have
created a will to kill more Jewish
babies and Palestinian babies CNN would
have been it I mean CNN is is is a is a
key factor in drawing the same sort of
equivalent to the c'mon so you're saying
that because CNN has interviewed
Palestinian families and shown
Palestinian children who have been
wounded or killed that somehow CNN gang
that Hamas is ok I don't think that
those two are equivalent we're not
allowed to show the civilians caught in
the crossfire of course you're allowed
to show civilians caught in the
crossfire you should also mention all
the restrictions that from us puts on
your reporting inside the Gaza Strip you
should also mention all the context with
regards to come us putting children in
harm's way you should also routinely
mention the fact that Hamas is charter
calls for the destruction not only the
State of Israel but for the murder of
Jews across the world which of course he
an end is not that that's silly Ben we
talk about that all the time we talk
about the Charter the Hamas charter that
says that they want to obliterate Israel
and wipe Israel off the face of the map
that's you're just not being fair that's
not true our reporter
occasionally in the you mention it
occasionally in the midst of vast swaths
of imagery about Israel using what you
would term excessive force Rula your
what's your impression of what's going
on this past when he said it is I I
think been is not in a position to
really lecture us about extremism
especially after what he said about
President Obama when he called him Jew
hater when he called him anti-semitic
and when he called for the expulsion of
Arabs in the West Bank and Gaza and Arab
Israelis like myself as a far as a
solution you know it's so hard to listen
to somebody that even Jeffrey Goldberg
called a fascist saying that I think the
issue about the public opinion will be
connected to the what happened
especially after the schools the UN
schools that were hit by by the Israeli
seven times after you and officials told
Israelis more than once actually 35
times they told of Israelis the idea
that they have civilians inside of that
school this is what turn the public
opinion against the action of Israel of
course Israel has the right to defend
itself against theirs attacks but when
every time that they kill one Hamas
leader one Hamas militant with him
they're killing at least 10 civilians so
the public opinion is asking what is the
end game here and after killing two
thousand civilians or two thousand
people is Israel really more secure and
safe let's try to avoid the inflammatory
comments about each other in the ad
hominem attacks because what we're
trying to get at is whether or not the
US impression the the general opinion in
the US has been fair towards Israel and
then I hear what you're saying you think
that it has not been particularly when
celebrities like Javier Bardem and his
wife Penelope Cruz issue open letters
condemning Israel and saying that they
have engaged in genocide but they don't
mention Hamas I think you're wrong about
the media I believe certainly the CNN
has shown both sides but there is an
impression then and I understand why you
feel this way it's certainly when it
comes to celebrities that they're giving
Hamas a pass well and this I think is
sort of the point with regards to
showing both sides when you're showing
two sides is equipped
and your idea of balance is to show
Israel's side and then Hamas aside and
then claim that that balance has been
achieved well that's the sort of media
coverage that would have led to the West
losing world war two so the one who's
actually equating Hamas and Palestinian
civilians those are not evil why would
you do that Hamas nature because you're
saying that when the media shows
civilians being killed there somehow
propping up Hamas that's not true it's
not what I said you're saying I did not
say that at all I said you feel free to
show civilians being killed what I
suggested is that you should provide all
the context for those civilians being
killed and as far as the other woman
who's on with me I'm not familiar with
her name you know as far as her personal
insults I mean I'm not going to get into
the quality of the movies that are made
based on her books I think we can all
stay away from that rule well let's talk
about reality and realpolitik and what's
and stay away from really ideology and
hate I would say look Israel negotiated
with Hamas more than once the last time
and the most striking one was in 2011
when they released 1,000 Hamas prisoner
for one Israeli soldier look the public
opinion especially the Palestinian
public opinion believe if you use
violent when you go violence we
negotiate with you while the PA the
Palestinian Authority in the West Bank
recognized Israel renounce violence and
got nothing in exchange and today the
world is asking what can we do about
this issue and move it in a context we
talk about occupation and blockade it's
really I mean a solution to your point
rule I mean wouldn't it just help if
Hamas decided to stop trying to wipe
Israel off the face of the earth I mean
that's the non-starter shouldn't think
that if he's associated with them given
that look Israel negotiated with Hamas
but look let's look at history Americans
and the British negotiated with IRA when
they were considered an extremist
terrorist group that would blow up
schools if we remember and actually they
signed a peace deal with them and they
agreed on a PC and they brought peace to
another island so this is the way you
negotiate with your enemies not with
your friends and finally you can put
that in context why we have cyclical
violence it's because of the occupation
and because of the blockade all right
obviously I both have very interesting
and differing perspectives bench pirula
jebel thank you for being here we'll
talk to you thank you for having us
thank you